human female orgasm is is a fairly novel
thing i have done studies with vibrators
and so on indicating that you know some
of the other great apes do seem to have
contractions i joke that i'm glad i'm
not the research assistant who had to go
to the gorilla and with the vibrator and
say
sign a consent form and then we'll do
something here
what do you mean when you say that women
shaped men more than men shaped women
does the biological argument that uh
men are changed are more changeable and
and
continue to evolve
faster than women do
has something and i'm not an expert on
this but has something to do with the
the y chromosome doesn't have the
backups
that the x does
so if
if you get a mutation on the x
chromosome
that produces something weird the the
backup the normal one might take over
and keep the person normal whereas uh
for at least half of the y chromosome
there's no backup
uh which means that the the men are more
changeable biologically
it
put it
men are nature's play things that
there's more
uh selection that operates on the male
than on the female
uh and as evidence for it there's just
greater variance
um
in in in males than in females
more geniuses and more retards in the
genius is more retards uh yeah even with
height which is a very genetic uh
the thing um
the difference between the tallest and
the shortest men is bigger than the
difference between the tallest and the
shortest women
uh
so
again nature produces more variety
on the mail
that i've talked some biologists about
whether this is plausible and
they sort of say yes but i haven't
gotten a firm straight answer
uh
you see to drive evolution forward
uh there are a lot of mutations some of
them are a few of them are beneficial
most of them are bad so ideally to
improve the population you want the bad
ones to be flushed out of the gene pool
you don't want them to keep reproducing
uh whereas the good ones you want them
to spread as as
as rapidly as possible
um
in our species and in many others
there's a both of those are more easily
accomplished with the male than the
female the thing is most
women
have a baby
throughout history
and hardly any have more than a dozen
whereas there are lots of men who have
zero
uh and there are men who have you know a
thousand
uh
and certainly it's easier for a man than
for a woman to have a couple dozen
uh even in these days with serial
monogamy and and so on um
so
if the sun has a really great new trait
uh then it will spread faster than than
if it's in the daughter
and likewise if the sun has a bad new
trait
it'll be easier to get it out of the
gene pool and not be repeated
that's such an interesting way to frame
it i really liked as well
your idea about the fact that um men are
the demand and women of the supply when
it comes to sort of the sexual
marketplace but that makes sense about
why women would shape men because men
typically are the sexual protagonists
they if women want men to um have a
house and a job and marry them before
they have sex with them then sure enough
men will stick to those norms if they
want them to be the strongest warrior or
the smartest crypto investor or whatever
it is like women kind of set the rules
of the game and then men go okay is that
what we're playing and then they they
try and just
do things i don't know whether you
follow steve stewart williams i'm gonna
guess that you probably will know who he
is
i don't okay so he's an evolutionary
psychologist wrote the the apo
understood the universe fantastic book
and he loves posting up um images from
nature animals a lot of the time birds
doing these ridiculous like extravagant
dances colorful plumage and they're
doing death defying stunts jumping out
of trees just trying to get women's
attention trying to get female birds
attentions i suppose but you do kind of
see basically the same thing and that i
think is what i liked about women-shaped
men more than men shaped women
yes it seems uh
have the impression men will do whatever
is required by women in order to obtain
sex
and not a whole lot more
and so women can set the norms uh
one book that influenced me earlier in
my career was uh marcia gutentag and
paul c card's book too many women
who went through a ton of data about
sex ratio differences you know some
societies have a lot more men others
have more women
um
and uh sure enough when there's a
surplus of men
uh it's not majority rule like in
politics it's minority rule like in
economics
uh
you know if there are too many men as it
were and not enough women the the
the supply is not equal to the demand
the demand is high and so
men really have to make serious
commitments and uh or do whatever women
want in order uh to have sex and when
it's the other way around
uh like after a major war that's killed
a lot of the men
or on today's american college campuses
where women outnumber men three to two
um
then the supply exceeds the demand and
so the price goes down in the sense of
what the woman can demand and expect and
a long-term commitment no
sexual fidelity no uh waiting until
marriage or whatever to begin sex no uh
and
if she doesn't adjust to the man then
the man can soon move on and find
another female partner
but of course it's reversed in places
where they're a surplus of men like in
america's wild west
or uh china during the uh the one child
period when there was a lot of selective
abortion
uh and
millions of surplus men uh then
then the price is high and the man
really has to make a serious commitment
and do whatever the woman wants
uh in order to get into a sexual
relationship
who did you find out was having lots of
great sex
well that's a uh
looked at the the research on that it's
very unequally distributed you know if
you just sort of casually read the
magazines and watch movies you get the
impression lots of young people are just
falling into bed with each other
very casually all the time
but the the numbers and the the survey
data tell
a different story
um
for
looking at people in their 20s
uh which is
the sexual dream age in the sense
everybody
younger than 20s wants to be older and
everybody older wants to be younger
uh
um
so if if you look at those people
um there are a handful of very
attractive people uh who are having
plenty of sex
uh and others a lot less i mean there's
the sort of pareto principle that it
shows up in a lot of things where
20 of people are responsible for 80 of
the action i mean this is true like even
in a scientific field you know 20 of the
scientists are doing 80 of the the
exciting new research and publishing and
so on um so
numbers
something like that maybe may be true
and it's a
it's true for both men and women but uh
again women are more selective so the
inequality is is bigger for men as uh
like i said i saw a small
fraction of the men are having the
majority of the sexes lots of women are
interested in them and the rest of them
uh can hardly get a a response
now i've read some
some
journalistic columns and
so on uh that
after 30 uh it changes for both men and
women but in in somewhat
different ways uh a lot of those men who
really couldn't attract a lot of
interest
sort of the middle of the pack
uh you know attractive men you know by
the time they're in their 30s they've
got more money they're a little more
grown up they have a little better
understanding of the world so
they find the
the women
are attracted to them um and so they
will do well uh the women uh in their
30s uh a lot of them are putting career
first and so on and uh
some of them start to complain where are
the good men we're not getting the
quality of men even that they got in
their 20s and they're sort of
disappointed to find that
some of the men
in their 30s just refuse to date women
in their 30s they don't want women in
their old age in their own age they want
they want younger women so
uh there may be this sort of
party
party cohort of men in their 30s and
women in their 20s
you're having a fine time and as i said
plenty of sex and it's it's exciting to
the women because the the men are
established and
have money and are doing well it's
exciting to the men because the women
are young and beautiful
uh but uh
but others others get left out
what about the great bit of sex lots of
great sex
lots of great sex well that narrows it
down some that you're you know just
going to bed with one person after
another
uh
doesn't necessarily produce the highest
uh quality of sex because
it's better if people get to know each
other and uh
um is that
uh
yes uh in terms of uh quality of sex you
know
people are more likely to
um
report a good quality interaction
with uh
with a regular partner
again there's a bit of a gender
imbalance there most men are not that if
difficult to
get to an orgasm whereas women's bodies
are more complicated and then maybe take
some time
to learn how to do it and so to please a
particular woman
might take a little more practice and
skill i believe i read some data that
even on the
the hookups you know with no future or
uh
you know commitment or anything uh the
woman's rate of orgasm is low but if she
hooks up with the same man twice even
without a relationship the second time
her her orgasmic frequency goes up
uh
all this suggesting again it takes it it
takes a little while so
i i saw the impression married people
and single people kind of envy the each
other i think the others having a better
sex life
um
the data suggests married people tend to
have more sex
for the single person there's often uh
feast and famine kind of periods you
know you might
have several people or
have an intense relationship and have a
lot of sex when you start out you're
often having sex every day or twice a
day
uh most marriages don't sustain that
uh but they're also long periods for a
lot of single people of of no sex at all
and
you know i'm friends with the great sex
researcher uh helen fisher and
she has national survey data saying the
majority of single people are now saying
they did not have sex one time in the
past year
um so
uh
when they do have it it's somebody new
it is often very exciting because it's a
new person
uh as i said there's the competence
issue on a first time thing but
assuming you figure it out and you get
to know each other and
have an ongoing period again you can
have a
a phase where you're having plenty of
very exciting sex
every day or
two or three times a day
and so the quantity is better and the
excitement is better but that's
compensated
by uh long periods when there's when
there's nothing yeah it's a trade-off
between uh novelty and
the advantage of intimacy right
sometimes novelty at least for men seems
to be an advantage but for women
intimacy and familiarity and
understanding
i read a great paper about how um
the they've done self-reports from women
about what it was that was getting in
the way of the orgasm and it seemed like
self-referential thoughts concerns about
performance uh expectation to orgasm
oddly was one of the biggest barriers to
women finding orgasm at least in this
paper and i thought that was really
interesting
but it makes complete sense because you
think about what gets released during
the female orgasm bonding hormones do
you really want to bond with a male that
you haven't become
familiar and intimate emotionally with
just because you managed to have sex you
know this would be
in cases of forced sex this could be a
bit problematic and i know that there
are cases where um i don't know whether
it's due to what happens during sex but
where women can sometimes almost fall
for sexual attackers in kind of a
bizarre way um see i think i think it
kind of it does make sense data about
sex
are
all a little bit weak you know a
scientist would wish for better data i i
can sometimes like compare sex and
violence
those are two big issues in any society
and so on but
in terms of being a social scientist and
trying how much can we learn about this
we can learn a lot more about violence
than about sex
because with violence you can do
laboratory experiments with simulated
things other sorts of aggression to
really test causal hypotheses very
carefully you have great real world
statistics in terms of murder rates and
so on
you know
sometimes reporting of
assaults and so on may may change
locally but even so you can look at
trends over time pretty good data on
that murder data tend to be quite
reliable in contrast with sex we have
very little like that other than other
than births uh which are also
objectively recorded so we know somebody
probably had sex if there's a birth
uh but we're much more relying on what
people say and what people say about
their sex lives is not
the unvarnished truth
uh there's illusions of wishful thinking
and and other things that intrude on it
so it's scientifically challenging it's
still worth doing because it's it it's
important but you want to know something
like how long does it take for people to
have sex
um
well i don't know anyone who sits there
with the wristwatch
or the stopwatch
keeping track so people may estimate
but
you know time sort of stands still
perhaps uh
i don't trust their their estimates all
that much either
what did you find out about the mystery
of female sexual desire
well um
the one reason it's mysterious is it's
it's more changeable
uh than the male one
um i i got this uh uh idea sometime i
remember reading history of the sexual
revolution and all the scholars who
studied it said that
well it was a change in behavior for
everybody but women changed much more
fundamentally than men the you know the
men after the sexual revolution
had a lot more chances to do what they
wanted
uh but their desires and all that were
pretty much the same whereas women's
attitudes towards their bodies and
feelings about sex and acceptance of
their desires and everything changed in
a much more fundamental way so i
wondered well why is that is that a
general property something about female
sexuality more changeable or was that
just some specific issue with the sexual
revolution
so i waited through a large amount of
other sorts of data and it's it's very
much true
the way i put it sometimes is the sex
drive everybody agrees is influenced by
both nature and culture i mean there's
your genes and your hormones and all
that
evolution uh but they're also societal
pressures and what other people are
doing and expectations and reputations
and all that stuff as well
uh so they argue about how much of each
is there my conclusion is that the
recipe is somewhat different by gender
the male sexuality being more on the
nature side
of female being more on the culture side
so you look at for example immigrants
when they move to one culture to another
the women pretty quickly settle into
whatever the new
the sexual norms are at the new place
uh whereas the men retain more their
their others they don't they don't
change as much uh or as in terms of
going through adult life
um
a woman's sexual desires at 20 may be
different from 30 or 40 and
she may try same-sex relationships or
take up masturbating or want to be
spanked or or whatever whereas the
average man
his desires at 2025 are pretty much the
same at 55 to 60 they're just you know
diminished a bit in
in intensity but he doesn't pick up new
ones as much
or another sign
uh we look at highly educated women and
uneducated women the masters and phds
versus the dropped out of high school
they have very different sex lives
education
really seems to alter the woman's sex
life whereas the men
are not all that different
as a function of level what's the change
related
what's the change that it makes to
women's sex lives
uh the the more educated women try a lot
more things do a lot more things they
are much less
traditional and conservative um
so have you got any idea why why you
think that might be
uh well i think one would say education
exposes people to new ideas and new
practices and
and so on
influences
um
and it's interesting religion it's
another way
another set of institutions also very
powerful in society and again the most
religious to first is the least
religious women have quite
different sex drives whereas the men are
almost depressingly similar
across that
um
and there religion sort of seems to push
in the opposite direction from education
whereas the
the higher you go in education the more
the woman is open to trying oral sex or
anal sex or threesomes or whatever uh
whereas with religion it's to go to more
highly religious the less she is open to
uh
trying these different practices and
multiple partners and all those things
uh so
so
again to this looking at this as a
social scientist it was really
interesting you have two powerful sets
of social forces of institutions in
society
pushing in opposite directions on the
sex drive and both having a bigger
effect
on women than on men
uh so
you know i noticed too uh back in the
sexual revolution when i was a young man
there were all these books explaining
female sexuality to them our bodies
ourselves and whatnot and
they didn't produce these books for men
uh there's some advice on on how to
understand the female body uh
and so on but there's a much less less
mystery there
so for a woman
so part of this is the complexity of the
the physical response perhaps but
also for a woman to understand her sex
drive it's a moving target so even if
she figures it out when she's 20 or 25
when she's 35
she may have different feelings
different patterns of desires and and so
on and what worked then didn't and for
the mail as i said
it's much less mystery to begin with and
once you've figured it out you don't
really
have to uh continue changing or updating
your your understanding of of what you
want one of the interesting things that
i saw was that women have the ability
but men have more motivation when it
comes to
their desire for sex but the way that
they actually perform during sex so
women have the ability to have more sex
multiple orgasms etc men have a
i mean even the most virile man has a
pretty big latency period after
having sex it's i just find it really
interesting that um it's the group which
has the biggest sex drive which is
actually restricted from
having sex or orgasming as much and the
side which perhaps has a lower sex drive
on average seems to be able to perform
more
yes um i don't know if we call it orgasm
about performance but uh but
depends depends if it's real or not
uh
well there is that
um
i think part of the answer is that the
male orgasm because it's so fundamental
and the process of reproduction
evolved much earlier
uh than the female
and so
the the
human female
orgasm is is a fairly novel thing
uh i have
done studies with vibrators and so on
indicating that uh
you know some of the other great apes
do seem to have contractions
i i
i joke that i'm glad i'm not the
research assistant who had to go to the
the gorilla and with the vibrator and
say uh sign a consent form and then
we'll we'll do something here
uh
but uh
but they somebody did it and uh
so they're capable of it they doubt that
it happens very often because the the
coupling doesn't last very long and the
male gorillas aren't really
uh caring much about pleasing their
partner and all that
um so sorry does that mean that most
other animals
dolphins and elephants and stuff that
the orgasm as a sensation isn't a thing
well i'm not an expert on this i i have
read some other experts who's
and it's not totally known again
human orgasms
to them
but it looks as far as we can tell the a
lot of them
there isn't even the capabilities of the
female orgasm
uh or if it's there it's probably not a
very common thing
one of my lines of thought recently is
that
in order
for humans to evolve the way we did and
to become these cultural beings there
had to be a whole bunch of changes
including bonding the male and the
female
for a longer time this goes back to you
need a bigger brain to do culture you
have a big brain it's going to burst the
uh
the birth canal
if it's there in the womb so it all has
to grow after birth which then
compared to other
apes
human babies are way prematurely born
this is all babies uh
you know a young chimpanzee can
kind of take care of itself you know in
a year or two um
whereas the uh
the human is fully dependent at least
till seven or eight and to some degree
till
into the teen years
um
so it needs
the father and the mother to work
together to provide more food
the human mother could not possibly feed
multiple children by herself
particularly when she's pregnant
again
so
for that whole thing to work they had to
get the man
recruited into the provider role and to
form the commitment to the women so all
kinds of the changes in evolution
from humans to others
starting with just facing each other
during sex
uh and kissing
you know facing you can look into each
other's eyes and form an attachment
there you mentioned both sides have
these orgasmic release of hormones they
start to feel love for each other
uh here was one of the surprising
findings during the early days of the
sexual revolution and people were just
out having sex all over with strangers
but yeah they still started falling in
love they weren't uh
able to uh keep them as a separate in
that
um kissing
uh and so i would consider the female
orgasm to be one of those that really
improves the quality of the experience
for both the man and the woman
obviously particularly the woman
and helps make them
[Music]
have this romantic love for each other
uh that bonds them together
uh for some years so that to the
children that come when you're having
sex will uh will be adequately provided
for at least until they're seven or
eight now you read about the the
hunter-gatherers and
as you know through
if you say
human civilization's been around for 150
000 years 140 000 we were 100 gatherers
and in those
yeah they do bond in a pretty monogamous
fashion
but only for a while by the time the
kids are seven or eight often
they're getting on each other's nerves
or the man is off to find another a
younger woman or or whatever but that's
enough to get the job done anyway this
more than you probably wanted to hear
but the female orgasm i look at as part
of that constellation of things that
helps bind a young couple together and
make them stay together through the
transition to parenthood and and through
the uh the early years of the the
child's life what about uh male and
female changes in sexual desire
when you get into marriage and during
marriage and then after having kids
uh yes well um
uh
i
read this uh book some years ago this
australian woman uh
a journalist with some social science
background uh
um
she had contacted me and
had a book called the sex diaries and i
wanted to know if she could get it if i
could help her publish it in america and
i didn't know what to do about that but
i read the book with great interest
uh she had the idea she would keep
keep records of people get couples to
keep records of their sex lives and it
would make a a racy bestseller with lots
of juicy details
uh and there was some of that but the
more of it was uh
the husband begging for sex and the wife
saying no no no or the
boyfriend and the girlfriend
or whatever and so she said it just
seems like
women go off sex once they settle into a
committed relationship that the
excitement the attraction is there for
forming the relationship not sustaining
it and it's certainly consistent with
the idea that uh
it's there
or in the female to form of the
relationship i think nature learned to
turn up sexual desire in the young woman
especially when she's sort of getting
involved with a man because that will
help him think oh my god this is great
um and
even if she's a little difficult to get
along with at times i have great sex
every day for the rest of my life this
is totally worth it
uh but then nature says once the bond is
formed that's checked off and
the natural agenda turns her attention
to bearing and raising a child
and so she's not so eager to have sex
anymore i asked to my relationship
expert friends uh if this was true in
the research literature this was you
know just the woman's
uh the journalists getting these people
to report it and they said you know it's
not known in the literature but we have
data that could address that and they
had both collected data on married
couples and they just collected tons of
data over the first five years of
marriage
so they went and analyzed the data
which showed essentially this
right at the time of the wedding the
man's desire
for sex is higher than the woman's but
it's a fairly small difference
it is still significant men are hornier
than women every every measure shows
that
but a small difference and then
across the first five years the man's
sexual desire stays about the same while
the woman's
progressively drops
and so five years into the marriage they
have a mismatch even though they were
pretty close
at the time when they first got married
and so this
bettina aren't uh in her book
um
the sex diaries uh her impression does
seem to be correct in in the research
um at least in these in these data that
uh
a female sexual desire tends to dwindle
and diminish once uh
the relationship is formed and the
commitment is established
uh so again i think it's it's
not uh it's certainly not something that
women are doing consciously
uh i think
i think often the women may even be
somewhat baffled and disappointed
themselves to find out that they don't
desire sex the way they did
this is one of those things
uh
a piece of advice that i read in mate by
jeffrey miller and tucker max
is
a lot of the time relationships can
begin and the couple are attracted to
each other and then if the woman comes
off the pill perhaps because they've got
married and they're deciding to maybe
have children her hormonal profile can
change and that can actually mean that
she is uh averse to
the smell of the man there's also some
data that i've seen in the final
month or so of pregnancy
that the woman can feel very
averse to the smell of her partner and
very um bonded to the smell of family
and this kind of seems to make a little
bit of adaptive sense that let's say
that you get into an argument with your
partner when you're heavily pregnant
that can be dangerous for you so you
stick with your genetic kin in an
attempt to kind of keep yourself
protected and i like both of those but
it comes back to this idea again about
the fact that the female
sexual
um drive is super malleable right and
it's constantly in flux it's changing
in response to its ecology what's going
on around it it's changing in response
to its hormonal profile now males
sexual drive is also in response to
testosterone levels right higher
testosterone level uh more desire for
sex more desire for new partners sexual
novelty
masturbation all that sort of stuff um
but that it's like the male sex drive is
like linear it kind of goes up and it's
do you want more of it or do you have
less of it the female sexual drive can
go left and right uh i think you looked
at data that said more women have
experimented um going or they swing more
from
men to women and then back again whereas
the bisexual category is a lot less
occupied by men
yes um
yeah
it's complicated there
i guess there are more
gay males than gay females
but the overlap between the bisexual
category is a much bigger proportion
of women who've ever had same sex sex
than for
men why do you think it is that there's
more gay men than gay women
oh well that
that continues to be debated now you
have to understand the the scholarly
issue or the scientific issue is
how does homosexuality continue at all
why is it not repeated out of the gene
pool yeah
yeah
nature is against it since it doesn't
reproduce
and a lot of cultures have been against
it although some have tolerated it but
certainly the last few centuries
you know so we look to nature and
culture as the two big explanations for
once they agree
on not favoring homosexual activity
and yet it continues to survive uh
there's some interesting uh answers uh
starting to emerge
uh you know my
colleagues in uh
at the university of queensland brandon
uh a paper in science and i think the
second one coming along
finding out that
okay yes there are genes
that predict
homosexuality it's not a particular gay
gene as they were once saying and
apparently they found one uh in contrast
it's sort of the combined activity of
hundreds if not thousands
uh of them
um
and the interesting finding
is that the siblings
of the gays who the heterosexual the
brothers and sisters are heterosexual
you know this so also is gay um his
brother is heterosexual and he has more
sexual partners than the average man
so the way i put it is that the super
manly man who only
is entirely masculine in all his traits
he doesn't relate to women all that well
it helps a man to be attractive to women
to have a little more emotionality and
warmth and nurturance and and all these
things they like some degree
uh of of feminine traits to be present
they like a manly man too
but some of it helps
so it becomes a hit the middle problem
uh you want to have more
of these genes which will produce more
feminine traits
in the man
but maybe beyond a certain amount since
they're being
mixed together at random in the in the
fetus
um
that
may be a high amount then
turns him to where he'd be more
attracted to other men
um
and so it becomes
his genes made him homosexual which
again nature doesn't reward since it
does
that sex doesn't produce children
but
the same configuration of genes just a
little bit on the other side of the
border produces extra
uh children
by making
others more more attractive and
and that's enough to keep the uh
the genes replenished in each generation
so it will continue uh to appear that is
so interesting so a couple of things
first off
one of the best tactics that you should
have if you're a guy that wants to be
successful with women is to have a gay
brother basically that genetically
you're going to have a hormonal profile
a genetic profile that's going to be
good for you and also it kind of
suggests that gay men
are a lot closer to highly successful
heterosexual men
than we might think you know you've got
not too far away from the genes also i
saw in your book didn't it say that um
monozygotic twins identical twins
have a 50 percent
likelihood
of the other twin being gay if one of
the twins is gay
yes uh those data for a while ago i
don't know
if there's any update or anything but
that was an estimate which shows there's
a lot of nature and a lot of culture i
mean fifty percent likelihood of being
gay that's way above the
probably two or three percent
uh
maybe maybe amongst four in the
population so it's if you're if your
twin brother is gay and you're an
identical twin yeah the odds are much
higher than average on the other hand
fifty percent is far from a hundred
percent it's not determined
uh
[Music]
and
again the true number may be a little
higher than that because some people
don't want to be gay
and will resist acknowledging it
uh but
nevertheless i think this is a sign that
there's ample input from both nature and
culture
what did you mean when you talked about
the tragedy of the male sex drive
uh yes well
uh i'm using the tragedy and the term
uh
in the more advanced literary criticism
arthur miller had a famous uh essay a
tragedy is not just something bad
happening uh but it's sort of a fatal
flaw in yourself and you're striving for
something great
uh but because of the flaw you
you fail he said
he said in a sense tragedy although it
has unhappy ending it's more uplifting
than comedy as comedy sort of looks at
people's faults and foibles and bad
things and so
and so i describe it as a tragedy i'm
not saying it's it's a calamity i'm not
even saying that it's that it's a bad
thing but uh it seems
doomed
uh
to falling short of its of its desires
that men were just instilled to
want
more sex than they're likely to get
um
i think a while ago we
cited some research by one of my
colleagues who surveyed her first-year
college students of uh well if you if
you
wanted uh how many people would you like
to go to bed with for the rest of your
life assuming it was all up to you don't
worry about diseases or laws or
pregnancy or anything it's just you know
to experience sex how many people would
you like to do it and
the average for the women was was two
and a half
and the average for the men was 64.
now with that there's a lot of
disappointment ahead for those young men
um but it's it's true now it must be
said a lot of the men just said i'd like
to have one presumably they hadn't had
any yet
and do you think well if i could get one
that would be perfect but the man has
had one kind of wishes he would have two
or three and manus had three maybe
wishes for six or seven and
i said ten may wish for
fifteen
and uh
you know i've known men who had over a
hundred sex partners and they were still
wishing for more
um
and that kind of again suggests this
tragic flaw aspect
nature did not design you to be
satisfied that
ah i've had my sex and it was great and
i'm done with that
no and
having it more makes you think of it
more so it stimulates more desire to try
new things and do new things with
different people or the same people
um
so
in that sense it seems
uh
somewhat doomed to frustration and
um
i've also been thinking in in terms of
the uh what i mentioned before
uh that uh we're talking about how women
shaped men
i think women probably shaped men toward
higher sex drive
as as i said other apes they don't take
fatherhood seriously at all the idea
that you should provide food for your
children
that would seem ridiculous to them and
especially doing it on a regular basis
over many years and even to the mother
of those children who after all is just
some gorilla you had sex with a couple
years ago uh no no that that would seem
ridiculous to them
and yet human males do this routinely so
when that was evolving
there were probably plenty of men who
had the same outlook that your average
gorilla does and say come on i have to
work twice as hard to produce twice as
much food every day and give half of it
to this wife and baby uh that seems nuts
and
well those men took themselves out of
the gene pool right
if they didn't want to play along uh and
put up with the supporting the women and
uh
you know
um i've known many women who are
delightful and
fine people and so on but inevitably
some of them are difficult and neurotic
and unpleasant and and all that and
uh well what's to make the man make the
commitment and and stay with them too
they need they need providers to support
them and their children
and the desire for sex is a strong thing
and so
i i'm suspecting that
the human male population has a higher
sex drive
than the animals we evolved from and
that they were specifically selected not
in those terms but uh
uh
the women would reproduce with the men
who wanted sex enough to uh stay
committed and
put up with whatever the woman's demands
and problems are
so a high sex drive would
would be selected there uh it's it's
ironic because of course women complain
about men being too sexually motivated
and
although they also complain when men
stop making advances and and so on it's
uh
it's it's a balance to strike it's a
difficult bargain you know
that i'm not a young man trying to
figure out what the rules are today as
they keep changing
have you considered uh have you heard of
the term post-nut clarity do you know
what that is
i have not okay so it's like post-coital
depression and i think it's
it's like nietzsche or freud or someone
that said after copulation the devil's
laughter can be heard
and i think he's talking about this like
such an apocalyptic way to talk about
having sex and pillar talk but um
many guys and girls as well i've heard
uh will be familiar with the
just had sex and then
sometimes this sort of like quasi uh
melancholy state can set in
i
do you think that this plays into the
requirement nature's requirement for men
to have a high sex drive that if you had
sex and you laid there in the full body
glow that i've heard typically is more
common of a female post-sex
uh environment
um
that that would discourage you from
going and seeking more sexual partners
and also post-nut clarity is now
something that you can add to your
scientific lexicon
yeah
um
this being said or depressed after sex i
uh
i haven't seen much about that i
spend more time on tick tock right loads
of loads of people on tech talk are
talking about post nut clarity oh
okay maybe i should try to find that as
uh yeah it's really not
something i've heard about from other
men i read about or they didn't fit my
own experience either
uh but um maybe they do it uh as to
whether it discourages people from
seeking new sex partners i i rather
doubt that that's uh
that's it that would
for example
i mean for one thing right after sex
hardly anyone goes leaping out and
running in search of a new sex partner
uh
the the new sex partners are
sought
you know later on different occasions uh
if you're single as you're just sort of
back on the market
and if you're in a relationship then uh
um
well people seek out other sex partners
for various reasons dissatisfaction or
just excitement or curiosity
but uh
but i don't know that
the effects of a particular orgasm could
last long enough to make any difference
yeah yeah
yeah um
what did you look at to do with
masochism and kink and stuff like that
oh
yeah i wrote stuff about that a long
time ago i was actually doing research i
wrote a book on how people find meaning
in life
um so
uh when i was reading for that i was
just sort of looking for interesting
stuff and i wanted some people who have
interesting lives that would lead me to
uh
give me some insight because back then
there was hardly any research directly
on the topic
um so i thought oh maybe those people
who like to be tied up and spanked and
all that
i bet they have really interesting lives
uh so i was on sabbatical university of
texas i remember i went over to the
library and
uh grabbed all the books they had that
uh dealt with this stuff and spent a
couple hours going through them and i
could tell pretty fast that i was not
going to learn anything about the
meaning of life
from
the kinky sex literature uh but it was a
challenge
one of my other lines of work is
understanding the self and
masochism just seemed to be directly
opposite to all the prevailing wisdom
about the self which is that you know
you want to think well of yourself you
want to have high self-esteem you want
to be regarded as a success and all that
and yet these masochists want to be
embarrassed and humiliated and put down
and so on uh we assume the self seeks
pleasure and avoids pain but these
people want to be tied up and spanked
and whipped and things like that
um
and the self wants to be in control
that's another
widespread basic assumption in
psychology that you seek to establish
and maintain control over your
environment
and yet the damascus wanted to be tied
up
and uh
ordered around and uh you know called
slaves and things like that
so i wondered
how to to reconcile these and and uh
you know there there must be some
illusion that the you know this these
facts about the self were so well known
uh there couldn't really be a contrary
evidence but eventually i was convinced
there was and in fact that's one of the
essential features of of masochism is
trying to get rid of the self trying to
escape
uh from self-awareness that
maintaining yourself and
being
confident and successful and all these
things
that involves a certain amount of stress
and then people like to
escape and forget who they are for a
while um
one of my colleagues j hull had been
doing a line of research on alcohol
obviously also very popular and he found
that when people drink alcohol they have
less self-awareness which is why they do
a lot of crazy things i mean you're
sober you don't get up on the table with
a lampshade on your head doing the
doing a wild dance
um
but uh
um
[Music]
so it seems there's an appetite for
things that get rid of self-awareness
and temporarily
even transform you into someone else uh
so these uh sadomasochistic sex scenes
uh seem to do that
i remember reading somebody was doing a
research project on the uh the call
girls in washington dc
uh thinking oh this must be a real
interesting lot you know that's the um
american government is there and so what
are these women like and they
interviewed a ton of them and well
turned out they were just the same as
color girls any anywhere else uh but the
clients that they had all sorts of
interesting information and there was a
lot of masochism in there
uh like i think they
said that uh
you know these are rich men who could
afford to do whatever they wanted but uh
the requests to spank the call girl
were
not nearly as common as requests to be
spanked something like eight to one
um
so
well you think these highly successful
powerful men
they have a lot more stress other people
are always trying to expose them and get
them down they have to maintain a really
larger-than-life image and keep up
this impression and get everyone around
them continue to believe in how great
they are
and so just getting rid of all that for
a while being tied up and
who knows dressed in women's underwear
and licking uh
the toes of a
of a paid sex worker
you can't possibly think of yourself as
a senator so and so while you're doing
that that it just gets you completely
out
of who you are and that that escape from
self seemed to be uh
a key part
uh of the appeal of that's that's the
best i could figure out uh
um so the the writings i did uh
we featured masochism as escape from
self the the sadism part the compliment
that's much more complicated and i i
didn't really get to
get as far with that for one thing there
are a lot fewer of those uh i learned
this was doing the research like the
clubs for s m they typically have four
times as many submissives as dominant
and a lot of the dominance started off
as submissives and then just thought
well
i could
give a perfect experience to someone
else by dominating them and so
it's kind of a vicarious submission for
them so
the dominant person they might have
their partner across their lap and be
spanking them but they're really
empathically connecting with the partner
and doing it just right to get to get
the person because
you know spanking is
as part of a sex game
is a dicey business if you do it too
much it will spoil the mood if you do it
not enough it'll be like
what was that for uh so again it's
hitting the right hitting the middle
uh getting it just right so it requires
a high degree of sensitivity and empathy
and attunement to the partner and people
who've had that desire and done those
things themselves
um
they they like to
you know they feel better able to do
that
i met this guy from the kinsey institute
i think when i uh
i was doing this research
and uh the kinsey institute they they
encourage their people to not only
collect data but to actually go and
participate uh in these things which is
not part of bloody hell that's one
problem
one hell of a request from your research
candidate
well you know he wanted them to be
welcome this goes back to kinsey himself
he said yeah we're trying to learn about
this phenomenon that everybody does but
there's no scientific knowledge about it
so go ahead explore it
go forth and be hit on the ass
anyway what he said was that uh he would
uh he found that if he could go up to uh
usually a
a woman although maybe a man too he
probably did both uh who was in the
dominant role i was sort of playing atop
uh and he would tell him i really have
this desire to dominate you
and he said there'd usually be a kind of
flash in their eye like this is exciting
to them because they they remember that
even though they're very much at the
present playing the the dominant uh role
uh
often they'd started out with the other
and they still had that kind of uh
excitement at someone proposing the idea
to them
it seems to me like a lot of the
um exciting stuff to do with these
sexual
taboos is is crossing a taboo line right
it's reversing the polarity of a role so
you have the high-powered
boss [ __ ] or ceo that wants to play the
other
role and i think that
the cute girl next door that dresses up
in leather and has a whip is an
archetype for a reason because you think
well that's her reversing her sort of
polarity her identity a little bit did
you look at um paul bloom's work about
the sweet spot because he interviewed a
bunch of dominatrix's
dominatrix for that and uh he was
telling me that he spoke to one that was
a professional dominatrix and she said
nothing captures attention like a whip
and what you meant by that was that if
you've been hit in the face for a few
seconds afterwards you're not thinking
about anything and that kind of leads
back to what you were talking about
there that it's people want
um
peace from mind right they want to
escape it's it's a type of escapism it's
the same as using drugs or alcohol it's
to get them out of their headspace you
know they've got this high-powered
executive who has to do things and he
needs to be executive function is
through the roof and then he's tied up
and what can he do
he can't do anything he literally can't
do anything yes
yes
i
i did this work long ago as before i
knew paul bloom and uh read his stuff
um
but that's true and i i did read some of
them make the same kind of comment and
one said i think a whip is a great way
to get someone to be here now because
they can't look away from it and they
can't think about anything else
now they don't usually hit them in the
face i think because they don't want to
leave marks there and plus that's that's
risky
uh i learned the s m communities really
careful they want to administer pain but
not cause any injury
um
so and and and dominance who actually
hurt their partners uh are often then
shunned and not welcome anymore
uh but uh but wherever they whip i'm
like the bare ass was i guess the
popular place
uh that uh
uh it's the same thing and it certainly
gets one's attention
what about pornography
you looked at that
all right well uh what about it it's
certainly
been a huge and revolutionary change a
couple centuries ago there was
there's very little there'd always have
been some erotic drawings
going back into prehistory
but the availability has been quite low
and i assume the quality was too
i think
i forget it was a remark that a young
man today
can go online and see more naked female
flesh in
in 10 minutes than his
great-great-grandfather saw in an entire
lifetime
um
so
it's clearly it's here to stay uh
i was young when people are still
debating should it be made available and
can stores sell it over the counter or
only
in the mail and
if it's too pornographic it should be
suppressed and censored and
even people put in jail
uh
now i think they've given up on most of
that there's there's so much sexual
stimulation available well that's i
don't know for better for worse
[Music]
and probably
some of both
um interesting question for me
uh is
to think of novelty as a limited
resource
that you can get excited by new things
uh whereas things that are the same
the same sexual stimuli year after year
will become somewhat less exciting uh to
you
so
uh
young men already have high
sexual desire it doesn't take much to
turn them on
in a way it's kind of a waste
to look at all that pornography and get
turned on there because
what novelty are you going to find in
your 40s and 50s and 60s
uh to produce
arousal there there's a
writer from the uk called mary
harrington and she did an article called
the three laws of porno dynamics and the
second law of porno dynamics is the law
of fap entropy which states that
whatever you start out wanking to will
get progressively more weird and novel
over time
and she's basically highlighting this
the fact that
this isn't true this definitely isn't
true for uh all men but
a particular
subsection of men
need to continue to amp up
the
extremity the novelty
whatever it is and then before you know
it you're down in the the annals of
pornhub watching blueberry porn or
whatever it is that you can manage to
get yourself into um but yeah i think
that that's that's a dynamic you're
right that um male's overclocked
sex
uh drive
gets really sort of weaponized and then
down regulated and then you've got to go
again like we need to ratchet it back up
again then it gets down regulated again
further because it just continues to
adapt
yes um
the novelty's there it's probably a
stronger factor in the male than the
female sex drive but
in some degree
new
new things are exciting new practices
new partners
new things
we think go back to like the victorian
period the late 1800s
women just were covered head to foot
pretty much and
i say like if if the woman's skirt came
up and showed her ankle
you know like the man might get an
erection
uh
turn on a big deal you know now ankles
are nothing and
knees and and all that
so
at least though that if you're getting
turned on by a glimpse of an ankle
as a young man then
um
there's still plenty that's going to be
new and you've got a lot of you've got a
lot of head room to descend into
bedroom and so this second law of
partner dynamics may
very well
have some valid basis and uh
and yeah i do uh
worry a bit about the young man i can
totally understand i mean
none of this stuff was available when
when i was young and uh if it had been i
can well believe i would have been
curious and
and passionate enough that i would have
gone ahead and exposed myself to it but
in a way i was lucky it was was not so
available and
[Music]
more things were still new to me and
later in life
one of the most interesting things it's
just a passing comment i think it was
your co-author
on this that said there were fewer
sexually transmitted diseases
ancestrally when humans had fewer
clothes
because skin-to-skin contact was more
common
and that meant that
the diseases were able to be transmitted
through from an arm to a back or
whatever because we would be sleeping
under a blanket together as a family
because we didn't have enough
hides to keep us warm and then you you
develop clothes
and
these particular diseases realize that
they need to mutate and one of the most
reliable ways to get skin to skin
contact is to be transmitted through sex
i just thought that was so interesting
uh yes uh that's my colleague dantes uh
um
she knows more about that than i do
so i don't know how strong the evidence
for that is but i know it's an important
and influential theory and and certainly
very plausible
uh with
everything i know
that uh
as we see diseases continue to mutate
and adapt uh so they can find new ways
of being transmitted and find new new
hosts
uh so yes uh the advent of clothing
really made it harder for those that
were translimited to skin to skin
contact and so
they started to become sexual
sexually transmitted diseases
there's also a section as well that i
thought was really interesting about the
suppression of female sexual desire like
in that the the fact that that's
happened a lot throughout our uh
culturally um
it's just it
it's one of those things where
because men typically were the ones that
were in power and
the male
insecurity or the the sort of cuckold
radar for men is so hyper attuned that
it kind of doesn't surprise me that it
would have been the sort of thing that
would have been suppressed because every
man was fearful of it
um well that's one of the classic
arguments about it
uh that it was uh
perpetrated by the men
when we reviewed that literature and
i've done many literature reviews and i
could tell in advance this one was going
to be a big tangled complicated mess
um but we dug up all the research we
could find and it was surprisingly
clear-cut that
the cultural suppression female
sexuality is mainly practiced by women
it's not the men who are doing it
um i think if you surveyed men and said
well suppose we could put something in
the drinking water that would reduce
women's libido by half
so all women
would have only half as much sexual
desire do you think the men would be
voting for that say yeah yeah let's do
that
i i don't think so so the idea that men
want to stifle women sex drive
so that they don't have to worry about
them that that
i don't i don't really think that's all
that plausible or that there's much
evidence for that
why why women doing it then
uh women doing it probably for the
the economic reasons we mentioned before
that uh
sex appeal is
in many cultures the woman's main ticket
to a successful and happy life
you know we all need resources we need
food and shelter and the more
you know nice clothes and all those
things
and that
[Music]
in most societies men produce the
majority
of resources and so women are dependent
on men to get them and get them mainly
in exchange for sex
uh often by marriage
you know sometimes shorter term
relationships or with sex work
prostitution even just you know a lot of
pay for
case-by-case basis but in all cases
the the higher the demand the higher the
price the woman can charge the more she
can get in exchange uh for sex and so
restricting
the supply
with the same demand uh means that the
price will be higher
it's particularly focused i mentioned
the victorians
so and that's roughly the period from
about 1830 i think
uh to the end of the century to 1900 or
sometimes they run it up to the
beginning of world war one
but in that period
women were much more prudish than before
or after
it was one of the most
intense uh cultural suppressions of
female sexuality
uh that we've seen
and that's probably no accident there
were several interesting things going on
for one
traditionally in the farms women had
plenty of functions you know the men
were still the boss of the farm but the
women did the spinning and the weaving
to make the clothes and the canning to
store stuff and so on and then the
industrial revolution
took over women's work
um so
like it started with the textile
industry so all that spinning and
weaving suddenly the women didn't have
to do that in the 1800s they talked
about something called the women
question like what are women good for
what's the woman's proper place in
society
they didn't quite have a sense of this
is because of the industrial revolution
that
suddenly changed the rules of the game
and taken away the economic functions of
women
but what that meant is that a woman had
a lot less to contribute
and so
sex became more and more important
you know a man wanting to run a farm in
say 1650 or 1700
really needed a wife and it didn't
matter if you loved her uh it didn't
matter you know you wanted to have
enough sex to produce children so that
they would take over the farm when you
got old but you didn't really have to
get along or anything the family was an
economic unit
uh but
by a couple centuries later the man
doesn't he's not a farmer anymore he has
an office job or something
and he doesn't
have that same need for female input
economically so
so her appeal again is is mainly sex
that
she's beautiful and he wants to have sex
with her
so uh restricting the supply
um made him willing to make the kind of
lifetime commitment
the victorian marriages probably lasted
longest in western history
um
that was a fact or two
uh that's because improvements of public
health meant that people lived longer
uh when you think of a marriage you
think like in the 1700s the average
marriage was 15 or 20 years because one
of the others would die
and then suddenly people marry at 25 and
they're living till 65. so they got to
put up with each other for 40 years
um
divorce was not available yet you know
the 20th century uh changed revoked
divorce laws and gradually became more
liberal and
some people put this rather cynically
they said well legalizing divorce was a
substitute for
for plagues
and illnesses that
kept marriage is short i wonder how many
i wonder how many people were in
victorian marriages just hoping that a
plague would come along they were like
like i i can't deal with this anymore i
just want to be i want to be taken out
well they were certainly stuck together
for a long period of time and uh
they wanted either their themselves or
their partner to be taken away they're
even sort of jokes about
people praying for their spouse to die
and then instead they they get sick and
die themselves and
isn't that ironic
um
so
anyway they
a lot of their adaptations to that they
were much more formal they weren't
sharing everything as much and husband
and wife would separately dress up for
dinner together and
all those things and maybe that helped
help them tolerate putting up with each
other
for a much longer period of time
than in the past
treating
the enforcement of sexual norms
of women by women and considering it
like a price fixing cartel that is sort
of unspoken between all women but
everybody in forces
i learned about that first in mate by uh
jeffrey miller and tucker max and they
talk about the game theory of [ __ ]
shaming so they say that um what they
what other women don't want to have
happen is for the price of casual sex to
drop below a level that they would be
prepared to get at so if one woman is
prepared to give [ __ ] on the third
date but you want to wait until the
fifth date it's in your interests as a
woman to apply social pressure to bring
the the price up
i mean first off that's just a
fascinating way first off
it is
counter to what most people believe
about where
norms and the enforcement of them come
from right it's mostly the patriarchy
and men that are telling women what they
should and shouldn't do with their
bodies the same goes for beauty
standards the same it's like look men
don't
men don't recognize the clothes that
you're wearing who do you think it is
that's telling you that you should that
pastel shades are in or that it should
be this kind of a dress or whatever
it's women that are doing that so the
cultural side of that makes sense
i had a theory
that have you heard of simps do you know
what a simp is
no
okay so this would be the sort of guy um
on the internet it's an internet speak
language a beta male who would be
fawning over a woman who evidently has
no sexual interest in him but he'll do
things for her maybe he'll buy her gifts
or take her out on a date in the long
distance hope that she may one day
decide to see him as a
potential partner um a lot of the time
guys that pay for girls on only fans or
support
sex workers without getting sex in
return are kind of seen as sims although
some guys that pay for sex work may also
be seen as simps and i had an idea that
in the same way as
[ __ ] shaming for women uh enforces the
price of sex and ensures that it doesn't
fall below a particular rate that
symptoming from men so men that feel a
particular amount of distaste for other
men who are
being
they would see as a little bit sort of
slimy and
um conniving
i think one of the reasons for that is
that the price of resources and
commitment without sex
is what men have to offer women in the
same way as the price of sex without
commitment or resources is what women
have to offer men and i think that
my theory was simp shaming is the same
male to male enforcement women don't
typically enforce
symptoming all that much well why would
you you're going to be the beneficiary
of this do you really want to say that
more men shouldn't give away more
resources and and time and money and
care and attention
for nothing in return why would you do
that but men have an incentive to do
that they're incentivized massively to
do that because they don't want
some woman to be able to go to the guy
next door not need to give up sex
but be able to get the resources and
attention and stuff so that was my uh
bro science theory around that
yeah um that that's intriguing and uh
plausible i don't know how much of that
is is going on
uh and uh
i
suspect the common reaction to men who
are doing that would be more just
feeling sorry for them um
if
there may not be enough of them to pose
a threat to the
artificially boosting the price of sex
so that the men are expected to pay
uh even without getting it um
and we noticed the laws have certainly
gotten that way i mean you can think of
marriage as uh the man contributes money
and the woman contributes sex indeed
people choose their marriage partners
partly based on those those criteria the
woman wants a good provider and the man
wants a a sexy attractive uh body
but the laws are at the point where the
woman's obligation to give sex
probably ends after the
after the honeymoon whereas the man's
obligation to contribute money
uh goes on for years even many cases
after the relationship is over so he's
not getting any sex anymore
uh any rights but he still has to uh
continue to pay
um
so
i suspect men would be more concerned
about things like that although
men seem to be
seem to be suckers concerned about other
things at the moment so rolling the
clock forward given all of this stuff
that you've looked at uh this imbalance
that we have currently in the dating
market more women in colleges two to one
pretty much by 2030 it's going to be
women out earning men between the ages
of 21 and 29 more women achieving status
and all that sort of stuff uh what
have you got any ideas about where the
sort of sexual marketplace is moving in
the future and what dating will be like
going forward because it doesn't seem uh
massively optimistic from
where i'm standing
well there are always reasons for
pessimism i could could come up with a
few more
uh that you know to the extent there are
these hook-up cultures and patterns and
that young men
uh being single
uh can have sex with a variety of women
without much commitment or expecting
to have to contribute much to themselves
that this is
this is exceptionally bad preparation
for marriage
uh
and so
adjusting to being married
may be
increasingly difficult uh for the young
men and especially if it's true that the
wife is going to be losing interest in
sex well
um
he's going from the single life where at
least there was a variety
of options there and periodically would
have episodes of great sex to having not
so much
um
and the sex being often divorced from a
relationship context or commitment that
also
doesn't seem to prepare the young men
well
uh for marriage
um
women also brought up today to think
they can have it all and have very high
expectations for what is owed to them
and what they're entitled to have and
and all that uh
they also um
so
as i say there are plenty of reasons to
be pessimistic
about the future of marriage on the
other hand marriage has been a durable
human institution
i remember being at a conference with a
bunch of family researchers across
multiple fields and
it was one of the points where the
politicians were worried about the
future of the family and
look the family is always going to be
there or it's the family's not going to
disappear yeah there are stresses and
changes and problems
uh and there always are and always will
be but uh it's it's not going to
disappear as an institution
so
marriage will continue to happen and
people will continue to figure it out
the declining birth rate is uh
is an issue for some concerned about the
the population and
apparently most
of the or just saw some data on this
that uh
most of the developed countries
the
the population that lives there is is
declining is not reproducing itself uh
and so it's only by virtue of
immigration
africa is the one exception where the
population is still continuing to uh to
increase
and it may continue to overflow into
into europe and other nearby places
[Music]
but
that's an issue and you know well do we
care does that make any difference where
the people come from their economic
issues when the population shrinks
are there environmental issues when the
population expands
um
you can always find something to worry
about
overall life has continued to get better
for most people so i have a generally
upbeat outlook
um and uh
despite all the the problems and the
misguided ways that we bring up boys and
girls um
[Music]
they'll probably still manage to find
each other and there'll be plenty of
decent people who will be glad to have a
long-term relationship with uh
with someone and now
someone of the same gender as well as
becoming an option and accepted in
society
um
so having a long-term relationship seems
to produce a lot of
health and well-being benefits
um
[Music]
there are certainly conflicts and
problems to be worked out but uh
i don't know i
yeah so
yeah i have a few concerns and some
pessimism and so on but in the long run
it's
the society will muddle through and the
population will manage and
[Music]
men and women will still find ways to go
to bed together and occasionally to make
make a baby good man i like it uh roy
baumeister ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
work that you do you've written whatever
is 600 papers and 30 books or something
like that where's best to keep up to
date with the things that you're up to
uh
well i guess there's a website
roybalmeister.com that uh
we update periodically with the new
stuff and uh i don't know i can be
easily found on online people want to
know what the latest is also doing a
blog for psychology today
uh the the book we talked about today
was the audiobook uh
um the what is the social psychology of
sexual interactions
um
and so there's there's plenty of stuff
there it's always a fascinating topic to
explore and and go on one of many but
but important one right i appreciate you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace